fertilization is the epic story of a
single sperm facing incredible odds to
unite with an egg and form a new human
life it is the story of all of us
during sexual intercourse about 300
million sperm into the vagina
[Music]
soon afterward millions of them will
either flow out of the vagina or die in
its acidic environment however many
survived because of the protective
elements provided in the fluid
surrounding them next the sperm must
pass through the cervix and opening into
the uterus usually it remains tightly
closed but here the cervix is open for a
few days while the woman ovulates the
sperm swim through the cervical mucus
which is thinned to a more watery
consistency for easier passage
once inside the cervix the sperm
continue swimming toward the uterus
though millions will die trying to make
it through the mucus some sperm remained
behind caught in the folds of the cervix
but they may later continue the journey
as a backup to the first group
[Music]
inside the uterus muscular uterine
contractions assist the sperm on their
journey toward the egg however resident
cells from the woman's immune system
miss taking the sperm for foreign
invaders destroy thousands more
next half the sperm head for the empty
fallopian tube while the other half swim
toward the tube containing the
unfertilized egg now only a few thousand
remain inside the fallopian tube a tiny
cilia pushed the egg toward the uterus
to continue the sperm must surge against
this motion to reach the egg some sperm
gets trapped in the cilia and die during
this part of the journey chemicals in
the reproductive tract cause the
membranes covering the heads of the
sperm to change as a result the sperm
become hyperactive swimming harder and
faster toward their destination
at long last the spam reached the egg
only a few dozen of the original 300
million sperm remain the egg is covered
with a layer of cells called the corona
radiata
the sperm must push through this layer
to reach the outer layer of the egg the
zona pellucida
when sperm reached the zona pellucida
they attached a specialized sperm
receptors on the surface
which triggers their acrosome to release
digestive enzymes enabling the sperm to
burrow into the layer inside the zona
pellucida is a narrow fluid filled space
just outside the excel membrane
the first sperm to make contact will
fertilize the egg
after a perilous journey and against
incredible odds a single sperm attaches
to the egg cell membrane within a few
minutes their outer membranes fuse and
the egg pulls the sperm inside
this event causes changes in the egg
membrane that prevent other sperm from
attaching to it
next the egg releases chemicals that
push other sperm away from the egg and
create an impenetrable fertilization
membrane as the reaction spreads outward
the zona pellucida hardens trapping any
sperm unlucky enough to be caught inside
outside the egg sperm are no longer able
to attach to the zona pellucida
meanwhile inside the egg the tightly
packed male genetic material spreads out
a new membrane forms around the genetic
material creating the male pronucleus
inside the genetic material reforms into
23 chromosomes the female genetic
material awakened by diffusion of the
sperm with the egg finishes dividing
resulting in the female pronucleus which
also contains 23 chromosomes as the male
and female pronuclei form spiderweb
black threads called microtubules pull
them toward each other
the two sets of chromosomes joined
together completing the process of
fertilization at this moment a unique
genetic code arises instantly
determining gender hair color eye color
and hundreds of other characteristics
this new single cell the zygote is the
beginning of a new human being and now
the cilia and the fallopian tube gently
sweep the zygote toward the uterus where
he or she will implant in the rich
uterine lining growing and maturing for
the next nine months until ready for
birth
[Music]
you